parlare della della semplicità è una
cosa molto difficile parlare difficile
chiunque lo sa fare parlare semplice
della semplicità è ancora più difficile
i teologi medievali dicevano che la
semplicità e la forma del vero il
sigillo della verità mettendo insieme un
concetto filosofico altissimo con la
purezza del cuore e con la semplicità
dello spirito
ora non posso non pensare a queste cose
nella città di san francesco san
francesco è il simbolo della semplicità
ma non c'entra niente con la semplice
otterà o con la superficialità
francesco è stato un grande santo ma è
stato capace di essere un grande
intellettuale capace di fondare
addirittura una lingua è un logo tema è
colui che ha fondato la nostra lingua la
lingua nella quale io parlo l'italiano
la semplicità è anche il contrario della
semplificazione
la nostra è l'era della semplificazione
l'età della semplificazione la
semplificazione violenta la
semplificazione uccide immobilizza ed è
tutto sommato pigra perché fa stare
ferme le cose invece la semplicità un
mondo caldo e un mondo ricco e un mondo
da cui possano venire 1000 mille
interpretazioni
quando si pensa alla semplicità non si
può non pensare al mondo dell'infanzia
quale sinonimo più potente ma anche più
equivoco cioè nel mettere insieme alla
semplicità e l'infanzia ma anche qui
appunto i bambini sono semplici ma
tutt'altro che facili da capire
i bambini sono facili da mare ma sono
molto difficili da capire i bambini con
la loro
debolezza con la loro fragilità sono
fragili ma la forza dell'infanzia che
portano dentro di loro è estremamente
potente ecco chi come gli adulti di
solito a che fare con i bambini e con i
nostri cuccioli e ce l'abbiamo sempre
intorno nelle nostre case
li vediamo dappertutto nelle strade
nelle piazze lo sguardo dell'adulto e lo
sguardo che semplifica il mondo
dell'infanzia che appunto è tutt'altro è
tutt'altro che semplice e la
semplificazione appunto il guardare
all'infanzia costruendo sul bambino
degli stereotipi e gli stereotipi cosa
fanno irrigidiscono il bambino lo vedono
come un bambolotto da coccolare un
peluche zucchero filato senza
l'intensità di cui invece è capace il
bambino lo vedono come oppure come lo
vedono come un piccolo adulto adulto a
cui chiedono di crescere in fretta a
riad child e il bambino che deve
crescere perché gli adulti non hanno
tempo sono troppo presi dai loro dai
loro impegni dei loro affari per
occuparsi di lui oppure il bambino come
super baby il bambino che diventa un
simbolo del prestigio per i propri
genitori guardate che figlio a 4 anni
pattina scrive in tre lingue e suona il
pianoforte
oppure il bambino delle competenze il
bambino dei degli illeggibili documenti
scolastici in cui il bambino viene
passato alla griglia e diventa appunto
un insieme un catalogo di competenze
oppure il bambino come mercato il
bambino come target di una macchina
molto potente che il marketing che è
letteralmente all'assalto dell'infanzia
ecco queste sono semplificazioni che
molto pericolose nei confronti
dell'infanzia quindi utilizzerei adesso
l'unico vero sguardo uno sguardo più
potente per restituire l'infanzia alla
sua forza e la sua grandezza che è
quello di maria montessori maria
montessori è stata una grande
scopritrice dell'infanzia ha scoperto la
potenza della della
di ap sword and mind della mente
assorbente ha scoperto i periodi
sensitivi ha scoperto questi drive
queste guide potentissime innate che ci
sono nella mente nel cervello del
bambino costruite non da un ingegnere
informatico da bill gates ma costruite
da una signora che si chiama natura in
più di 500 mila anni di evoluzione bene
montessori
mi viene da pensare che quando guarda
all'infanzia
c'è una splendida frase di un grande
scultore che si chiamava brancusi che
diceva che la la la la semplicità e una
complessità risolta quello che appare
semplice in realtà hai dovuto fare un
lunghissimo giro per arrivare a capire
realmente che cos'è un bambino che non
sa c'è dietro la semplice vita di un
bambino
ecco montessori ha guardato in questo
segreto mondo dell'infanzia e ne ha
scoperti segreti ne ha scoperti cento
anni fa e le neuroscienze e tutte le
scienze che stanno studiando agirà mente
il cervello del bambino non hanno fatto
altro che scoprire e confermare quello
che montessori aveva capito cioè che il
bambino e il padre dell'uomo e non
potremmo tradurre aggiornare questa
affermazione dicendo che il cervello del
bambino e il parte del cervello
dell'adulto perché perché il cervello
appunto che non è una macchina e se
l'abbiamo capito adesso utilizzando i
computer nelle macchine potentissime è
la cosa più più complessa dell'universo
lo sguardo verso la profondità
dell'universo astronomico era la
complessità dell'universo biologico che
ci portiamo dentro fa sì che oggi le
neuroscienze ci facciano vedere che cosa
quale lavoro impressionante
voi pensate per addormentare un bambino
ci vuole il doppio di anestetico perché
per spegnere quella macchina che ha più
neuroni molto più neuroni di quella che
ho adesso sto utilizzando malamente io
cioè il mio cervello e la mia mente ci
vuole molto più anestetico il doppio di
quello di un adulto perché una macchina
molto potente ma non si vede perché
sotto traccia perché troppo semplice ma
per scoprire questa semplicità come
complessivi bisogna risolvere una grande
complessità e montessori montessori l'ha
fatta perchè ha scoperto i periodi
sensitivi c'è il bambino è pieno di
guide che dicono a lui che cosa deve
fare
eccola allora la sua
il fondamento biologico della libertà la
libertà è un grande valore si può fare
appello dal punto di vista religioso
filosofico a questo valore ma in realtà
montessori fonda la libertà sulla sul
programma è nato sui maestri innati che
il bambino si porta dentro di sé e
guardate guardate la mano del bambino
questa piccola mano che va verso le cose
questa piccola mano che afferra le cose
afferrare con la mano significa
letteralmente afferrare con il cervello
ma come facciamo a capire questa cosa
allora se io vedo un neuroscienziato che
con l'imaging mi mostra quale attività
esplosiva c'è nel e costruttivo perché
vengono costruiti da questi gesti da
quello che il bambino sente respira
tocca viene costruito vengono costruite
le reti neurali e il bambino è molto
lento in questo perché perché sta
costruendo le strade su cui noi
correremo una volta diventati adulti una
volta finita l'età più potente quella
magica quella in cui tutto accade cioè
l'età dello sviluppo quando appunto c'è
questa capacità costruttiva questa
piccola mano quello che afferra diventa
rete neurale la mano è davvero la parte
visibile del cervello e quando la mano e
la mente si separano
chi ci rimette sempre la mente e oggi
noi vediamo appunto anche nei più
semplici gesti a 14 mesi un bambino
indica un oggetto questo salto evolutivo
il mio gatto non lo può fare nessun
altro animale può capire che indicando
un oggetto mi coordino con lo sguardo di
mia madre che guarda all'oggetto
io so che mia madre ha una mente questa
mente la posso condividere questo a 14
mesi
questo significa che dalla coscienza
episodica degli animali
siamo passati alla alla conoscenza alla
coscienza mimetica è un salto evolutivo
impressionante nel semplice gesto questo
bambino indica una cosa non sa ancora
neanche parlare siamo prima addirittura
del linguaggio quindi pensate quello che
viene scoperto oggi
e c'è un apparato pedagogia tra poco
scopriremo addirittura una pedagogia
prenatale perché tutto accade quando
chiesero a freud quale l'anno più
importante della vita e questo genio
rispose ma il primo naturalmente è ovvio
che sia il primo eco montessori ha
scavato come nessun'altra dentro
chi sta dentro questo dentro sé del
tesoro e ha capito che la forza
dell'infanzia il bambino è un operaio
diceva lei e il costruttore dell'umanità
non fa niente perché appunto in quello
che fa un bambino sono giochi semplici
giochi facili costruisce oggetti
assembla perennemente in movimento
perchè nè lui c'è l'istinto del lavoro
ma questo lavoro non è produttivo di un
mondo di case di oggetti di sculture di
pitture i palazzi è un mondo però ben
più potente perché quello che sta
costruendo questo operaio è l'uomo del
futuro quello che dice avrebbe chiamato
loew bernes
cioè il superuomo e se questo questo
lavoro viene viene lasciato alle guide
naturali che il bambino è dentro di sé
questo bambino può diventare davvero
molto più potente davvero anche molto
più intelligente ma l'obiettivo non è
diventare semplicemente più intelligente
ma è aiutare la vita questa è la
concezione dell'educazione e montessori
a educare aiutare lo sviluppo cioè
lasciare libero il bambino di fare le
cose il più possibile da solo la
spontaneità la semplicità è il contrario
però dell'improvvisazione diceva una
vecchia battuta del living theatre per
essere spontanei nel gesto atletico in
qualunque cosa ci deve essere un
lunghissimo studio
ecco montessori cura i dettagli
l'ambiente montessoriano la casa dei
bambini è un ambiente curato nei
dettagli perché perché i dettagli
affascinano i bambini i bambini dicono
la messa celebrano i dettagli i bambini
hanno un vedono l'invisibile appunto il
periodo sensitivo dell'amore
all'ambiente gli rivela cose che gli
adulti non capiranno mai non potranno
mai vedere ecco ci sono degli adulti che
conservano questa capacità di vedere
anche da grandi non so come vedere un
campo di grano vincent van gogh o non so
che cosa vede essere gli uccelli e
francesco d'assisi aveva conservato
questa potenza creativa infantile
stabilizzandola come direbbero gli
etologi con gli psicologi in età adulta
ma noi questa questa questa potenza e
spesso e volentieri la spegniamo insomma
ecco il montessori invece costruisce in
maniera dettagliata perché la mente si
nutre di dettagli
e la mente del bambino si appende ai
dettagli li celebra e dentro il
dettaglio e la cura dei dettagli perché
l'ambiente montessoriano è un ambiente
semplice ed elegante ma dove c'è un
potente ordine che aiuta il bambino che
ha afflitto da un caos dentro di lui
quello da cui nascono appunto le stelle
insomma poi viene aiutato ad essere ad
ordinarsi interiormente per cui c'è una
purezza direi davvero un altro dei
sinonimi nella mia testa nella della
semplicità una purezza del materiale
montessoriano che è un materiale che
permette di fare molto con molto poco
la purezza dei triangoli costruttori la
purezza delle forme geometriche oggi in
un mondo così affollato così rumoroso
così invadente o con case piene di sedi
di oggetti e con strumenti di cui si
stiamo vivendo adesso molto belli e
molto potenti che però sopra
sovraccaricano il bambino allora quella
purezza di un triangolo costruttore a 4
anni non potrà mai essere sostituita da
un tablet che ti illude che il mondo
abbia tre dimensioni ma lui c'era
soltanto due esposti con il touch screen
con l'indice ma con quel questo gesto è
molto povero in realtà e ci sono
macchine che fanno fare molto poco con
gare con un grande apparato ecco
montessori al contrario fare fare molto
con poco perché perché c'è la fiducia
nell infanzia e la mente del bambino che
fa tutto il resto gli oggetti di cui si
serve sono quelli che servono per questa
attività costruttiva e pensare dei
giocattoli di oggi
quante volte ci è capitato di andare in
un negozio di giocattoli ed uscire
delusi perché non trovi un giocattolo in
realtà in un supermercato affollato di
giocattoli ma questi giocattoli spesso e
volentieri hanno senso si sottomettono a
quella che è stata chiamata la pedagogia
del tasto play
spingi e lui fa le cose sono macchine
pigra in realtà o che anzi macchine
potenti che all'alta definizione del del
mezzo producono che cosa la bassissima
definizione del messaggio perché poi
quello
ti viene fatto sono macchine che giocano
con i bambini non bambini che giocano
con le macchine montessori oggi è più
forte di ieri perché perché sa benissimo
che devi creare un ambiente in cui devi
favorire la concentrazione chi è la
madre della concentrazione o il padre
della concentrazione
la madre della concentrazione alla mente
assorbente che lavora che quando il
bambino è assorbito da un'attività che
lui interessa polarizza la sua
attenzione diventa sordo a tutto il
resto è il padre della della
concentrazione che è il silenzio quella
lezione del silenzio che montessori ha
sempre amato ha sempre esaltato diceva
saint exupéry che il silenzio e il
musicista dei frutti i frutti anche
adesso le mele ricati maturano nel
silenzio non c'è bisogno di grandi
discorsi e il silenzio è un profondo
rispetto
come creare un ambiente bello e
attraente per il bambino e poi lasciarlo
agire e il profondo rispetto non puoi
fare una lezione di morale al bambino
dicendogli ti rispetto o sui valori i
valori vanno praticati non predicati
eccolo montessori il rispetto alla
pratica attraverso la creazione di un
ambiente in cui il bambino possa
concentrarsi silenziosamente scegliere
gli oggetti e agire liberamente
facendosi guidare da queste potentissime
e insostituibile guide che si porta
dentro quindi lentezza nei gesti nelle
parole precisione nei materiali un
ambiente costruito che è un altro
sinonimo della della semplicità e
l'essenzialità
niente di troppo il troppo davvero è
nemico del bene in questo caso troppi
oggetti sono come troppo pochi perché
non aiutano questa questa concentrazione
ecco montessori ha capito questo e molto
altro e ha persino capito le possibili
degenerazioni e ci possono essere anche
nelle stesse neuroscienze e sono
estremamente riduttive che spiegano la
psiche con la mente la mente con il
cervello e il cervello appunto è una
cosa ma in realtà montessori vede dentro
la mente la potenza dello spirito c'è
una dimensione trascendente emergente e
si possono spiegare non i livelli alti
con quelli bassi ma far vedere come
emerge dal livello basso perché noi non
sappiamo dove andrà questo bambino non
lo sapremo
la cosa che so però è che lei e lei ci
ha aiutato a capire fino in fondo che
l'infanzia è
fatale perché questi bambini non
sappiamo dove andranno tra vent'anni
noi sappiamo che in passato dei bambini
che poi sono diventati degli adulti che
hanno subito una pedagogia nera una più
adeguata della violenza hanno sputato
l'inferno sul mondo e hanno rischiato
davvero di distruggere l'umanità
altri sono stati dei grandi benefattori
l'infanzia e fatale è semplicemente
fatale perché perché le ferite
dell'anima infantile poi si riverberano
per tutta la vita ma se noi aiutiamo dei
bambini a diventare meno infelicemente
adulti dei loro genitori e milioni di
bambini possono rappresentare un energia
biopsy tiga biologica un'energia
rinnovabile così potente che possano
realmente cambiare il mondo